so kata i wanted to start
with you on this when you were writing
did you envision the birth scene taking
place in a wonder
and if not what did that shooting style
bring out of your writing that maybe you
didn't even expect
okay um good question i was i wanted to
be
for sure as detailed as possible i
didn't i wasn't
expected this to be a runner but i was
sure
uh it needs uh space and time
because i wrote like around like 20 30
pages
i wanted to you know bring all the
emotions
uh that are possible during the births
why because i didn't want to just you
know depict uh
tragedy and the loss but i also wanted
to establish the love
that you know marta feels towards to the
baby and also
the presence of the baby which then
takes us
you know through the whole inner journey
uh of
marta so i think this perspective that
it is
that's that the spirit is there all the
time was really important for me
um and then when cornell uh and ben was
talking about how to
put it on camera i was
i felt like this aspect that we were
talking
is is right there with the with the
runner and also with the gimbal later on
yeah cornell i wanted to know about
specifically choosing
the moment to start that oner and the
moment to end it did you always know
that it had to begin with her water
breaking and it had to end
with the ambulance yes it is i mean
what was even even there is not the
water breaking but the most
first phantom pain is coming that was
the moment when when
when when i would like to store and
ended up on the ambulance
also because we don't want to show
exactly what's happening
you know when our exit is from the scene
somehow when we
when we saw the last time the baby she
is good and
and we have this infinite love so we
have to stay with it
and that's why i find it that we have
the ambulance car we have this big noise
you know and uh but it's but it we don't
know what's happening so the suspense is
staying into the movie
and the tension that what's going on so
when that next shot
when she's just walking back to work
you're not sure
you know i mean it's you know how what
what was it
so you slowly discover that is that she
lost the baby
i've got one more one or question for
you because that sequence is just so
incredible
how do you figure out exactly where to
put that on your shooting schedule is
there any fear that starting with that
could be too much or do you need to
start with that so it informs their
performances throughout the shoot
i desperately wanted to shoot as first
thing i really felt that is no way to
continue the movie
without this experience and uh
and and you cannot play somehow
uh without the
without that that tough role
physical variety of emotions what you
what you have to feel there so i
i i thought that it has to happen in the
first day so
and at the end you know i mean it it was
tough but in a way it was like our abc
you know
it was like okay this movie wants to be
like that
this movie wants to target that quality
of acting
that movie wants to target this kind of
team behind so
that was very important and very
miracles
seems like a challenge but one that
makes sense to me
another element i love about your
shooting style is your coverage choices
in particular the heated conversation
between ellen and vanessa at the family
get-together
for a scene like that when you're
shooting do you know
exactly who you want the camera to be on
when or does that happen in the edit for
you
no i mean it was decided and also there
is like
the psychological reason how we shoot
that scene it was like
okay when is the when is the storm
coming okay
so we really would like to expand time
before
about the nothing and we just we just
following vanessa
and we we are with her and and also a
little bit the reaction to
from the family and you know everybody
is watching her almost like a thriller
and then you know a samurai coming and
that's ellen bursting
and started to talk to her finally
let's say that and that's what you are
expected since
long in the movie when it became like
something real for a moment
and and and and then i decided to stay
on ellen's face
lonely like i don't know it's a two and
a half minute shot
for the monologue but it's just like wow
talking close-up
which is uh which is highly important
because the human face
you never be as close to a human being
as you can be with your camera and i
think this is also power of movies
as much as a water or a or a or a or
or you know like a white shirt on a
mountain it's it's everything there
what was it like when you found out that
martin scorsese was going to get
involved because i believe that happened
later on in the process right
yes i mean it's amazing i mean i was
very very happy and then
you know i mean his movie changed my
life in a way you know you can
you can't be the same person after to
watching a scorsese movie so i felt the
same with
alice doesn't live here anymore and the
taxi diver and all those things so when
he called me
and and i was like oh my goodness it's
it's happening with me
but at the same time he thought
something very clever that you know
cornea this is more an experience than a
film
and i was like exactly that's what i
want to do that was like so important
for me to create this whole inner
journey as an experience from a woman
who triumph her own grief and became a
stronger person
that was that was in me and he's really
worded the best way so i'm i'm very very
happy and i can't be more proud that
he's part of our team
you feel exactly what you just explained
when you watch the movie so
thank you guys so much for sharing the
story i loved it
thank you so much